la loire selon fleuve sauvage une source
d'inspiration inépuisable pour olivier
debré paradoxe pour quelqu'un qui
n'appartenait pas vraiment un courant
mai à l'abstraction lyrique tels que
l'on définit les critiques d'art de
l'époque on a une véritable gestuelle
mais qui est contrecarré en fin de
compte par cet élément extrêmement
liquides de sa peinture c'est aussi
comme ça qu'on reconnaît olivier de
britpop à la fois par le geste qu'on
sent néanmoins mais également par cette
très grande transparence de la peinture
c'est plutôt une tendance de la peinture
qui qui tourne le dos à la figuration
qui mise tout sur le geste sur la
matière sur le mouvement tout jeune à te
dire en histoire
je rêvais de ses tableaux et sa mère
énormément marqué
on ne peut pas garder un artiste comme
celui ci originaire d'ici à la marge
olivier debré disparu en 1999 a toujours
aimé la nature au point de capturer
certains détails sur ses toiles s'il
était très attaché à la loire il a aussi
beaucoup voyagé notamment en norvège
[Musique]
dans les années 70 il s'y est rendu à
plusieurs reprises le coup de foudre a
été immédiat
[Musique]
un pays où l'environnement change en
permanence avec ce ciel si spécial
embrasé en hiver
bienvenue chez frédéric née regarde ce
galeriste a rencontré l'artiste à
plusieurs reprises il apprécie vraiment
les arias sion et les changements dus
aux saisons
certaines peintures sont faites en
automne avec toutes ses couleurs
d'autres sont faites l'hiver olivier
debré a tout de suite été exposés et
apprécié par la critique et les
collectionneurs norvégien à chacune de
ses visites il a arpenté le pays en long
et en large
surtout la région des fjords il a
séjourné plusieurs fois à l'art dalle
plus à l'ouest
alors voici la rall de nuit on peut voir
les grands coups de pinceau la façon
dont tu agis la térébenthine sur l'huile
s'est dispersée par dessus parfois la
toile était allé au sol
ensuite il y à ces zones en appela à
chaque fois ou presque
olivier debré peint à même le sol et
cela se voit sur les toiles beaucoup
d'entre vous trouverez des brins de
paille ou d'herbe car les toiles étaient
transportés dans les bois et placés au
sol
il y avait même des petits moustiques ou
des insectes et parfois on peut les
retrouver dans la peinture
et frédéric neergaard se réjouit la
plupart des oeuvres qui manipulent vont
bientôt avoir une super visibilité elles
vont prendre la direction de tours où un
lieu est dédié à l'artiste le centre de
création contemporaine
olivier debré
[Musique]
des dizaines de réalisation ils seront
exposés à tour de rôle et le moins que
l'on puisse dire c'est que le lieu sera
à la hauteur
[Musique]
cette oeuvre pour moi toujours été sous
estimés pour mille raisons qu'on
comprend et il faut vraiment se battre
pour qu'elle reprenne vraiment sa place
sur la scène internationale
c'est ce qui va se passer avec ce lieu
tout juste sortis de terre un chef
d'oeuvre d'architecturé signé de lagence
eres matthaus à lisbonne on y trouve
plusieurs salles monumentales dont ce
gigantesque cube ouvert s'emporte un
ensemble adapté aux oeuvres de debray et
un nouvel écrin majestueux pour le
centre de création contemporaine qui
existe depuis près de 40 ans à tours
nous accueillons les cinq très grand
tableau 9 mètres sur quatre ce que nous
avions commandé pour le ccc à la
dimension exacte des cimaises du centre
je lui avais demandé ces tableaux et la
passa dans l'ehpad et on les a installés
pour une exposition dans les années 90
et c'est pour ça qu'il souhaitait que
nous en soyons les héritiers pourquoi
parce que il avait alors plutôt envie
que si ceux ci ne se passait quelque
chose
après son décès ça soit il reste avec
l'art vivant et claires des jeunes et
ils voulaient pas se retrouver dans un
musée entre une commode louis saez et un
tableau 19e
le souhait d'olivier debré sera exaucé
ce centre n'est pas un musée mais un
lieu vivant un espace de création où
viendront travailler des artistes du
monde entier un outil complet avec des
espaces blancs ou noirs ainsi que les
scènes monumentales comme la nef 10
mètres de hauteur autant de largeur et
32 longueurs c'est ici que sera
accueilli l'artiste norvégien père
barclays pour moi c'est le renard de
l'expo c'est chez lui parce qu'elle
mettait des prêts et des artistes
français le plus connu en aurais-je donc
dans les zones est même dans les années
60 70
c'est le le leur l'artiste français par
excellence excellente chez nous à
l'image des photos réalisées ici il va
créer dans la nef une chambre d'huile au
sol qui va refléter la totalité de la
salle moi je travaille avec des liquides
parce que ça reflète sa crainte est un
miroir mais quand même ça donne en
profondeur ça quand on alpha en fast 2
nation pareil ça donne le vertige
parce que même s'il ya le liquide à
seulement 5 cm de profondeur
tu penses que quelqu'un voilà c'est 7 10
m de profondeur
[Musique]
sous ses airs bucoliques la norvège est
un pays en pleine ébullition sur le plan
artistique
si la scène locale a mis du temps à
éclore elle est depuis quelques
décennies en plein essor et n'a plus
rien à envier aux autres pays européens
[Musique]
oslo n'est pas qu'une ville moderne et
ordonnée elle cache aussi de beaux
petits secrets des ateliers aux allures
de squats c'est dans l'un d'entre eux
que travail
ignacio le byssus plasticien et vidéaste
il réalise des performances comme ce
dialogue vidéo retranscrit en musique
à l'actualité
j'aime travailler avec la réalité qui
nous est accessible mais d'un autre côté
aussi pour la rendre irréel comme de la
science fiction lui donner un côté
imaginaire mais chaque chose est
connecté au réel a aujourd'hui un autre
problème une certaine façon à tous il y
aura une sculpture un muscle gonflable
qui va entourer le bâtiment d'une
certaine façon le tenir là ce sera un
muscle noir par rouge un muscle abstrait
en fait de tubes gonflables et de blast
use of hope l'article
autres artistes accueillis à tour tôt
rivera naissent ici en performance à
sydney inclassable cette plasticienne
revisite un mythe nordique celui du
troll elle change son apparence et sa
voix et se produit partout dans le monde
pour elle le personnage du troll est
universel j'aime mes matières plastiques
jamais leur jouer avec la réalité
la rendre plus abstraite créer une sorte
de réalité en dehors des normes
j'aime déformé mon propre corps j'aime
les grosses mains les gros pied les gros
ventre d'alès
[Musique]
la spécialité de toury des performances
in situ elle est déjà venue en repérage
ou cc cod et la date de tours est notée
en gros dans son agenda
ayvaz le détour je suis déjà venu à tour
il y avoir le bâtiment pour la première
fois mais j'ai été soufflé c'est fou
d'arriver dans un lieu où dix neuf qui
n'est même pas encore là tous sont le
neuf tout est immaculé ga de salir tout
sorte et c'est dans cet espace noir avec
des ouvertures que ces deux derniers
artistes se produiront une fois à tour
un lieu conçu pour la création
contemporaine avec des panneaux de bois
amovibles une salle modulable à l'envi à
l'image du centre
ça reste un lieu de création
d'innovation
c'est un lieu qui n'est pas un musée
dans la mesure il n'y a pas
d'installation permanente d'oeuvres et
annie stockage ni accrochage définitif
ou pérennes ici tous les mois il y a
quelque chose de nouveau et les
expositions partent d'autres sont
refaites
d'autre part et d'autre s'installer puis
il ya la vie du centre avec les
programmes de conférences échanges
situé près de la loire ce lieu à
l'architecturé novatrice contribuer au
renouveau total du quartier il deviendra
bientôt un pôle d'attraction notamment
avec le tram et deux grands hôtels de
luxe en construction à proximité
dès le départ j'ai compris que la vie
ait souhaité qu'on entre dans sa ville
avec un lieu culturel
c'est vrai que refaire toute cette ce
centre ville nécessité d'avoir un lieu
ouvert sur le monde sur la vie sur la
ville et ses formidables tout va se
reconstruire par rapport à ça on veut
que ce quartier les commerces quand j'en
parle je parle avec les commerçants on
voit bien que que les choses commencent
à bouger kenya une clientèle qui va
arriver nouvelle c'est un quartier qui
se refait entièrement après des années
de travaux le centre s'apprête enfin à
ouvrir ses portes début mars pour
l'équipe en place qui se bat pour l'art
contemporain depuis 40 ans ce n'est pas
un aboutissement mais un nouveau départ
une belle page à écrire on construit un
établissement public sur la durée donc
ça se résume pas aux sentiments de
quelques-uns c'est vraiment un
engagement de toute la ville ça et c'est
quand même le premier bâtiment culturel
conçu depuis l'après-guerre à tour c'est
quand même ça qui est le plus émouvant
par le reste du monde elle reste du
monde va pouvoir nous parler ça paraît
pas les artistes sont les vecteurs les
plus formidables qui soit
ce centre correspond à ce qu'était
olivier debré à la fois voyageurs et
passeur outre la norvège il s'est aussi
rendu au canada en chine au japon et a
été exposé partout son oeuvre continuera
de résonner avec les artistes du monde
entier le sait c'est cod s'apprête à
vivre un grand voyage il compte sur le
public étranger et espère attirer chaque
année cent mille visiteurs
il y a